et vous savez ce qui va se passer eh
bien nous allons bientôt manquer de
l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois devant
vous un verre d'eau précieuse puisque
avant la fin du siècle si nous
continuons un tel débordement elle
manquera
[Musique]
à lundi je vous dis au revoir et
j'espère vous revoir pour vous expliquer
notre projet global d'avenir merci mes
amis
il passait pour un hurluberlu à l'époque
mais il n'avait pas tort il a fait un
coup absolument magnifique je m'en
souviens très bien parce que j'étais
passionné de politique à l'époque et
donc je suivais ça avec avec avec
passion je suivais tous les débats
politiques il ya les giscard mitterrand
etc et tous les autres ça vous a pas
ancré dans l'écologie printemps n'ont
pas du tout d'ailleurs il se trompait il
disait avant la fin du siècle on est
vingt ans après le siècle et on ne
manque pas d'eau et personne ne manque
d'eau alors qu'il y ait des problèmes
écologiques qu'il y ait un réchauffement
climatique très bien mais je vous dire
très mal mais en tout cas il se trompait
dans lequel réduction de quelques
décennies seulement commandes de
quelques décès mais vous n'en savez rien
vous n'en savez rien moi je ne pense pas
qu'on manquera d'eau
je pense je crois je crois à deux choses
je crois à l'adaptabilité
infinie de la de l'espèce humaine et je
crois au génie humain qui va trouver des
solutions techniques comme il a toujours
trouvé comme il a toujours trouvé pour
se sortir des situations qui paraissent
des impasses donc si vous voulez sur ça
je crois profondément maintenant ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il n'y aura pas de
difficultés de crise voyez de
catastrophe mais
moi je pense si vous voulez que la
catastrophe qui menace la france ce
n'est pas une catastrophe écologique
mais c'est une catastrophe démographique
et c'est un remplacement de population
et un remplacement de civilisations sur
notre sol je pense que en 2050 la
population française sera à majorité
musulmane voire africaine et que donc ça
ne sera plus la france et que c'est pour
cela que je me suis présenté à la
président à l'élection présidentielle et
c'est pour cela que je me bats pour
empêcher cela voyez chacun à ces
catastrophes ces prédictions moi c'est
la catastrophe que je vois venir est qui
et qui me taraude le plus parce que je
suis attachée d'abord à la france
[Musique]